okay great so thanks for inviting me to
talk and I'll be picking up basically
where guy left off talking about some
recent work we have on evidence-based
rankings it follows in the multi group
fairness perspective and this represents
joint work with Cynthia twerk on Moran
gold guy Rothman Galliano and it will
appear at Fox this year so the
motivation for this talk is that often
ranking is sort of the underlying
motivation for prediction so for
instance you can imagine Cal Berkeley is
running college admissions and maybe
when applicants come in they'll predict
some probability say the probability of
graduation within the next four years
and then after developing some
prediction they'll select the top k
applicants based on this estimated
probability and so this is a way in
which the prediction task is really just
a means at getting at some underlying
ranking ranking is also at the heart of
a number of alternatives to affirmative
action so for instance in Texas
the top 10% rule was enacted basically
as as an explicit alternative to
affirmative action where the top 10% of
the graduating classes in Texas are
automatically accepted to state-funded
public universities I think yeah some
form of this is also true in California
and the but the point is that somehow
you need to rank individuals before you
can even hope to do something like this
so the concrete tasks that we'll have in
mind is to try to learn to rank
individuals by some probability of
outcome where again we'll refer to this
P star this probability of an outcome
given an individual or the features of
an individual and so for concreteness
you can think of this probability as
being the probability
graduation within four years or in a
very different setting may be the
probability of needing medical attention
in the next hour so for a medical triage
or you know wide variety of applications
but the challenge is that typically we
don't observe probabilities in the real
world what we observe our outcomes so
you know we might have access to a rich
set of features about an individual but
oftentimes we can't say resample from
this distribution or this probability
distribution over outcomes so for
instance when we say we might have
access to did the person X graduate
college in four years we can't then go
back and say you know try a different
college run for another four years and
see how you do again you know one over
epsilon squared times and you know now
we have some estimate of P star no this
is more subtle we have access to sort of
binary outcomes zero one outcomes say if
you did graduate or you didn't and now
we want to go back and sort of estimate
and hope to rank people based on this
underlying probability without direct
access to it so for instance it's not
sort of this setting is subtle and
challenging for a number of reasons but
one concrete reason is you can imagine
flipping two coins with different biases
and just look at the single outcomes
based on of these two coin flips
comparing the coin flips tells you very
little about sort of how to compare the
underlying probabilities or the
underlying original biases
yeah so for now for now just think of it
as the probability of outcome given the
features that you observe in some
underlying data distribution it's just
the Bayes base risk score how much then
you some reason you want if that was
your goal not you right so no I I agree
and so this is sort of a question of
like limited or bad proxy right like
really what we want to predict is like
your probability of success or you know
quality membership in the cal berkeley
undergraduate community but versus the
benefit
right so so so certainly certainly the
outcome or this the outcome that you
choose to predict the probability of it
matters immensely and so for the sake of
this talk will assume that sort of we
all agree on what the outcome is but I
think it's a great point that their
subtlety even in determining what their
task is and what we want to rank
according so as we've been saying the
goal will be to learn to rank
individuals according to some
probability of success without observing
these probabilities directly only
observing outcomes and we'll be
concerned with notions of accuracy as
well as fairness and we'll touch on
these as we go along so before I do
anything else I want to suggest that
ranking is a more subtle task than
prediction itself so as we talked about
the first idea you might have is to
learn a predictor and then rank
individuals according to the predictor
that you've learned and we'll see that
even if you're able to very precisely
recover an approximation to this
underlying risk piece start it gives you
very little guarantees about the ranking
that you might produce so let's consider
the following two example suppose it in
our population SMT P star is distributed
or sorry yeah you know there's two
populations SMT and the risk is
distributed as P star of X and s is 1.0
you know they're all going to be
positive outcomes and in T they'll it's
much lower 0.1 and suppose it in our
predictor that we learn we even get all
of T correct we get it precisely we
learned some P that is you know
perfectly predicts the individuals in T
but in S you know we do a very poor job
we predict them completely wrong we get
predict them zero point zero but now the
point is that if s you know has
probability mass less than or equal to
epsilon then the predictor on the right
will be epsilon close to the predictor
on the left that's to say that we
basically any epsilon accurate predictor
can sort of rank the induced in the
induce ranking can rank them arbitrarily
a group of size Epsilon so one thing to
note here is that this kind of
transposition could be viewed as
mistreatment both for s and for T even
though we've learned perfectly in the
group t so for instance if we were
trying to predict you know depending on
your task basically being at the top of
the rank or the bottom of the rank might
be good or bad so essentially the point
here to observe is that somehow ranking
feels like a much more global task than
prediction in other words miss
predicting in S or in some small group
might actually affect the ranking of
some much larger group even if you
understood that group very well
so as my talk suggested I'm gonna talk
about evidence bank based rankings and
I'll go through some set up as well as
sort of our first notions of some some
notion of fairness even when you can't
maybe recover the ranking exactly so
let's go through some of this at first
so as before we'll have you know as is
standard in prediction we'll have a
distribution over individuals as well as
a distribution over outcomes where the
outcomes are sampled according to
Bernoulli of this piece star and we
receive labeled samples and a small
number of them we hope to learn some
ranking now that will generalize and
ideally we would learn something that's
close to the true ranking and even if
this is not attainable we want to have
some guarantee over the the way that our
ranking ranks different groups of things
so again the challenge here is that we
don't have direct access to this beast
or if we had direct access to this P
star then we could hope to implement
sort of a comparison Oracle or something
of this nature and exploit techniques
there yes sorry Q star is a vector and
it's the Bernoulli parameter for each
individual
so so while this setting is challenging
again one thing that we could hope to do
from a small sample is estimate
statistical queries in particular
because of the way that we assume
outcomes are distributed based on P star
we can assume that for a fixed
collection of subsets for each of which
are sufficiently large in our
distribution that we can get our hands
on accurate estimations of this expected
value of P star in the subset based on
the empirical expectations of Y so in
other words this if we had a class C of
statistical queries we'll think of it
over a collection so right so so for a
collection C of statistical queries the
we can hope to from a small sample get a
uniform convergence bound and and say
that with high probability our estimates
in the sample will reflect that of the
of the true underlying risk and that
this class of tests provides reliable
evidence and ways to reason about the
rankings even without direct access to
piece
so there's quickly there's been a lot of
prior work on ranking individuals and
learning to rank but often almost all of
these works assume some sort of
comparison oracle or some sort of access
to this underlying piece star or the
underlying sort of ranking itself I
think our work maybe is most similarly
motivated to the work of Kearns Roth
whoo and having talked with Steven a
little bit about it I think our work
maybe sits sort of before their work in
the pipeline where we're trying to
estimate somehow these the ranking and
then once you do that you maybe can do
interesting notions of affirmative
action cross selection so just some sort
of there's a tight connection between
ranking and prediction and we'll see
some of that here so one thing that we
have been alluding to is that every
predictor induces some sort of ranking
so if I lined the individuals up based
on their probability or their predicted
probability I can map those into a
ranking and you know I can do that
formally I don't think it's too
important for this talk and we have some
convention that the smallest individual
and the ranking like is the is that the
best according to similarly every
ranking has a family of consistent
predictors so in particular if I was
given a ranking I can then map them into
some plausible predictor based on based
on the rank that I've been given and
this should be monotonic it should allow
for ties but not for crossings so for
instance this is one consistent
predictor but this could be a very
different one right Maps individuals to
different probabilities
so I'm gonna get further into some of
our notions of fairness now and revisit
this original example of so the main
concern that were that we have with this
sort of issue of ranking when
approximate recovery isn't enough to
guarantee recovery of a ranking is that
somehow our ranking would consistently
undervalue certain subsets over others
so for instance recall that this was
somehow the original ranking according
to P star but our estimated ranking sort
of transposed these groups and what
happened here what what feels
objectionable about this ranking is that
we had a set s whose outcome probability
the expected outcome probability was
significantly larger than that of T's
you know P star here is the expected P
star is one versus zero point one but
yet the ranking favored T over s sort of
universally and so this is the type of
this is a type of inaccuracy in the
ranking that feels blatantly
inconsistent with the not only with sort
of what we feel is good but is blatantly
inconsistent with with the evidence at
hand
so in particular if we were able to
identify this group s and T a priori and
we could you know measure a statistical
query on each of these groups then this
ranking blatantly violates the evidence
so to be a little bit more formal about
what I mean by the ranking favors one
group or another we have this notion of
domination and so the formal notion
isn't too important but you can think of
it as saying that there's that one group
dominates another that s dominates t if
there's like a downward matching from T
into s such that all of the in the
matching all of the individuals in T are
ranked better than their counterparts in
s and we can generalize this to sets of
different cardinality so this leads us
sorry is this notion of domination clear
no no sorry I'm saying I'm saying that T
dominates us within our ranking so
parameterize by ranking giving a ranking
then T dominates us within this ranking
if there's this downward matching
good so this leads us to a natural
notion of domination compatibility so we
we say that sort of informally if the
probability of success is higher in s
then in T then T should not dominate us
in the ranking right so going back here
this was precisely the problem that
happened in this where the expectation
in s is significantly larger than in T
but T dominates s in the ranking so this
is our first attempt at preventing such
transpositions
and again we won't just want to apply
this for a constant number of sets or a
set of sort of protected groups but will
try to apply the multi group perspective
and enforce this notion for a rich
classes of groups defined possibly by a
computational class so the formal notion
is that a ranking R is C domination
compatible if for all pairs of sets s
and T from this Class C if T dominates s
then sort of the expectations match the
expectation of T is at least that of the
best one outlier that's higher than
great that's a fantastic question so
we'll complete in how I've presented it
here yes but we handle this kind of
approximate domination in the paper so
so it's not an issue that it's a great
question
yep so it's it's another great question
and and you yeah the the question is
what's the notion of domination when the
sets have very different cardinalities
and and it's a great question it's it's
a little bit technical but you can
imagine drawing sort of a vertical line
here and thinking about this matching is
defining some sort of crossing or
talking about sort of where individuals
are relative to the vertical bar and and
it's it's it's technical but it's not it
makes sense once you I don't want to get
into it we can talk about it offline if
you and and yes again sort of our formal
notions that we work with them the paper
allow for additive approximations here
and and handle this approximate
domination as well
good so so why do we what intuitively
why did we feel like domination
compatibility is a good idea well so
these violations to domination
compatibility feel objectionable in the
sense that it feels like there isn't a
consistent predictor underlying this
ranking that respects the evidence given
by our class C and in fact we can prove
a lemma that that sort of exactly says
this so the lemma says that suppose T
dominates s in R if a predictor is
consistent with this ranking R then the
expectation of P in T has to be at least
that in s so that's to say that if R is
not C domination compatible if this
ranking isn't compatible in this way
then there is no consistent predictor
that respects the tests given by C in
other words this ranking cannot be the
true ranking right because we assume
that this true ranking arose from P star
which is a consistent you know which is
a predictor that's consistent with the
truth so this is one justification for
why domination compatibility makes sense
but sort of we have this objection that
there isn't a consistent predictor that
respects the evidence given by C we
could go a step further and actually
require that there be a consistent
predictor and this would be some sort of
strengthening of this notion so this
motivates a new notion that says a
ranking is good if there exists a
predictor that does respect the evidence
given by C that's consistent with the
ranking and this is exactly our next
notion which is evidence consistency and
so formally what we say is that a
ranking R is C evidence consistent if
there exists a consistent predictor P
such that for all sets in our Class C
the expectation of P under s is equal to
that of P star that's to say that it's
it's it's respecting the evidence in the
data so some properties evidence
consistency implies domination
compatibility and this is basically
direct from the lemma on the previous
slide and further this notion of you
know accuracy on on the empirical or on
the on the expectations given by C is
exactly the notion that guy just
presented of C multi accuracy so another
way to say this is that a ranking is C
evidence consistent if there exists a
consistent C multi accurate predictor so
it's a much it feels like a much
stronger condition than just this
domination compatibility in that we're
requiring that the ranking actually
respects some the ordering of some
predictor that is somehow globally
consistent with the evidence at hand
right so so that gets into this
interpretation that in some sense this
globally consistent predictor this multi
accurate predictor is what justifies
this ranking any questions
right so again this would be this would
be the idea this is what we would love
to get our hands on and it might not be
sort of either computationally or
statistically feasible and so so this is
somehow the our best way into that right
that if all we have are these
statistical tests then then we can't
hope to say that on an individual level
that we're consistent but at least on
these large groups that we can audit
we're consistent
so so sort of mapping out these various
motions I know that there's a lot of
them but we can we can sort of see what
in the predictor rolled we had this
notion of multi accuracy and it's very
tightly connected to this notion of
evidence consistency which we said
implied this intuitive semantic notion
of domination compatibility in the
ranking world so then we turn to the
question of actually learning such a
ranking how do we get our hands on one
of these things well we can reduce
learning or ranking to learning a
predictor as we wanted to in the first
place but now we can do it in a way that
we get some guarantees over these groups
so in particular the induced ranking of
a multi accurate predictor will be
evidence consistent almost immediately
based on the definition and the
connection to multi accuracy and thus
will also be domination compatible and
as as guy talked about we have a
learning algorithm for multi accuracy
and we can reduce this problem to
learning over see yeah yeah so so
evidence consistency implies domination
compatible oh sorry so you want
something that is evidence consistent
but not domination it's not it's not
bi-directional
its strict what's in Orono so yeah there
is there like a simple example of how
you can test by one enough the other
it's a good question no no so so
actually this is something that we we
struggled with for a while but you can
actually so in our paper you can see you
know whatever section it's in and
actually we can construct instances
where the tests will sort of be locally
consistent but not have this global
consistency in a way that that actually
demonstrates the fact that domination
compatibility is actually a strictly
weaker in those and there is an example
in the paper but it's but it's subtle
and and it's it wasn't a priori clear
initially we thought these notions might
be
it's a good question we great it's it's
we we reduce it to the problem of
prediction but it's a it's a so
especially because of our model of
access to the data I think this is very
natural we're only getting to see
outcomes of individuals so in a sense
our information is about there somehow
is statistical information about the
outcomes of individuals so it's very
natural to then try to learn something
that is consistent with a predictor and
then turn it into a range in other
models where you get access to these
comparison queries of is X rather than X
prime it's much more natural to rank
directly yeah comment the question so
the first comment is you said we're
learning to rank that the retirement
related to work that there's not that
much of it that deals with this kind of
binary outcomes but there's actually a
lot of it okay anything that there's a
ton of work in that area on clicks so
clique is you know a binary outcome
trying to predict what's the probably
some click on something but all you
actually have our flex or Netflix and so
that I see I see I see I see okay good
to rank there where you want to predict
for that and make sure that you're
putting people that are you know if you
had to rank people who are gonna show
and/or show what good good so so it is
learning to rank in the setting of a
binary outcome but but it's also going
through this reduction to predict
exactly okay we're guys name takeaway
yeah build a predictor and then rank
based on them yeah I'd love to get those
reference and then the question is just
like is a holdover from the first talk
is there some sort of objective that you
can say you're doing great please send
it in here so for the multi accuracy and
multi calibration in some ways yes ready
for the right for the ranking it's not
it's not I think I'd have to it's not
obvious to me where right and yeah so so
I don't think our notion is directly
related to any of them I think in a
sense sort of generalizes from these
individual pairwise notions to a group
right version of it so by the way for
the click prediction can you clarify is
it in fact ranking or is it above
thresholds my recollection when they
last saw this stuff in real life in 2014
it was above threshold so the
if the probability was above a certain
amount well you do all kinds of things
with it's the same thing where you build
a predictor and then rank things in any
of you to choose top K or actually
produce the ranking no it's kind of what
happens if the outcome is another
question but there actually is something
that where the data is very good when I
saw this in Bing it was predict the
probabilities and if it was above a
certain threshold then they were
candidates for the app I see so yeah but
I think even just on URLs you're gonna
think of URLs for a query and rank a URL
query great thanks so happy to take it
offline so now with these you know with
with our sort of landscape of sort of
various notions of ranking fairness
conditions and a way to learn rankings
that satisfy these conditions natural
tasks are we done yet
where are we there yet and what we'd
like to say now is that actually even
though we get these strong properties of
no transpositions in these groups
defined by this class see maybe we're
not done in particular we're going to
look at the weaknesses of these
predefined statistical tests and see
that actually there's a number of desert
errata that we might ask for that are
not yet satisfied so in particular let's
try to poke at evidence consistency and
and see how we can abuse it so suppose
that our our reality was over on the
Left where P star in our population s is
about 0.8 and in T it's about 0.5 and
this is uniform across the groups now I
want to I want to come up with a ranking
where some amount of T dominates s and I
want to do this because I'm malicious
but I note that my expectation of P star
is only 0.5 and the expectation of P
star in s is
larger than that so using p-star I'm
going to have difficulty in particular
this set that I've called t1 and s they
violate the domination compatibility and
so this wouldn't be evidence consistent
but but P star isn't the only predictor
we're allowed to use recall that the
definition of evidence consistency said
that there must exist a predictor that's
consistent with the ranking that
respects the evidence and so the
question is does there exist one and in
fact there does we can choose some
predictor P and assign the individuals
in t1 to b1 and assign the individuals
in t0 to be 0 and note that the
expectation of this p is equal to the
expectation of p star on this set T so
even though this feels somehow like
we're blatantly abusing this ranking and
ranking some group over this other group
s that is more qualified the ranking
satisfies evidence consistency with
respect to these groups SMT what we
would love is to somehow provide some
guarantees with respect to t1 and t0 and
s but the problem is that t1 and t0 were
not included in our class C in fact
they're only defined after the fact
they're only defined by the ranking in
question a priori we had no notion of a
t1 and t0 there's no t1 and t0 on the
left so somehow we have to augment our
understanding of what is a reasonable
class what is a reasonable statistical
query we can ask in order to hope to
guarantee this kind of prevent this kind
of domination incompatibility yep so is
your predictor no longer just untested
no this predictor could be deterministic
why would you get for the same
or are these different you can imagine
they're different X's yeah there's many
individuals within T but if they're
different X's the t1 and t0 are no
defined by something other than the
ranking no no no the T is just T is a
subset that's defined by say the first
attribute in X and only depends on the
first attribute and but but like if
you're saying that t1 and t0 are
different on some other attribute right
no not necessarily so yeah I mean I
guess so but but the point is that that
according to the tests that we've
defined this class C which we're taking
just to be the class s and T this is all
the that our notion of rankings know
about this is the only evidence that it
has access to so taking this sort of
like complexity perspective of like C so
you're like algorithms for learning
multi accurate predictors we'll learn a
circuit that's only like slightly more
complicated than C so if you like
wouldn't this problem be so just by
taking as your class see the bigger
steps
so actually so I want to argue that this
isn't just an issue with like
adversarial manipulation so consider the
following scenario where s has
expectation 0.75 and T has expectation
point 5 a very reasonable thing to do
that I think our multi accuracy
algorithm would basically do is use some
max entropy predictor and if you don't
know what that means don't worry about
it but but the it's a very natural idea
of how to predict and in this ranking
according to this predictor s would be
ranked above s intersect e above T but
in fact the true underlying
probabilities might be that s has you
know s minus T is 0.5 the intersection
is 1.0 and in t minus s it's 0
so the the true ranking would in be have
s intersect e above s above t so in fact
there's no way to certify this without
looking at this intersection that again
was only defined a posteriori after you
specified the rink so it seems analogous
the multi calibration alright as
calibration it's all defined based on
the we're doing great yeah so so we'll
see that there's actually a very tight
connection to multi television so so
what we in some sense what we want to do
is we want to incorporate information
about our current predictions in order
to inform our statistical queries that
we make right and so unless so in a
predictor we can look at the level sets
that's sort of the notion of statistical
tests that will we'll look at the
individuals in a certain prediction
range in a ranking we can look at the
quantiles so in particular there's this
idea that rankings once you have them in
your hands then they define the
important sets for instance you can
think of the individuals who are ranked
in the top 10% of the ranking and these
sets actually interact in very
interesting ways with the sets in your
statistical tests so in particular you
could ask for the individuals ranked in
the 40th to 50th percentile who are also
in CS asset in your predefined class of
tests
and so this is basically some technical
way of saying that we can define new
statistical tests that say I want the
expectation of s of P star or
expectation of P star in S conditioned
on the fact that your rank is in the
range T and so in particular because
these quantiles these sets that were
defined by the ranking violate
domination compatibility this will not
satisfy some stronger notion so we
define a series of reflexive evidence
bank based rankings based on domination
compatibility and evidence consistency
and where we're taking expectations now
we're investigating our rankings based
on the statistical test so we've that we
defined up front but also the current
ranking we're letting our statistical
queries depend on the ranking in
question and so as before this stronger
notion of evidence consistency implies
domination compatibility over this class
of tests but the surprising thing is
that the reverse implication also holds
in this stronger setting let's just say
that if a ranking is C our domination
compatible it's C our domination
compatible if and only if it is C our
evidence consistent so in other words
once we allow our our class of
statistical queries to depend on the
ranking that we have in our hands these
notions are equivalent so it reveals
some surprising strength of this
semantic notion of domination
compatibility so when the when the sets
that we query are allowed to depend on
the ranking in question then domination
compatibility implies some notion of
global consistency and as I mentioned
earlier it actually does require this
notion of self reference like the
regular vanilla C domination
compatibility is a strictly weaker
notion
so as rich is getting at like again we
have this very natural feel is very
familiar to this idea that we had in
multi calibration where we're defining
statistical queries based on our prior
queries and based on the ranking and
that in our hands and so we also prove
some very tight connections between
evidence consistency in this stronger
setting and multi calibration so the
theorem is that basically these notions
are equivalent as well so our picture
before was that we have this predefined
class C and we had some implications and
once we allow our tests to depend on the
ranking question all of these notions
are essentially the same so I'll just
finish with saying that this actually
gives us some interesting perspective on
properties that you get from multi
calibrated predictors in particular if
you use a multi calibrated predictor for
ranking then you get these non
transposition properties basically for
free and it strongly suggests that this
idea of multi calibration really
encourages this global learning across
all populations
[Applause]
so we so okay so we're so one thing that
I didn't include in any of my slides was
an additive alpha slack factor so once
you allow yourself some slack and you
just require that you get within this
alpha ball of sort of calibration with
respect to P start then like these
issues of convergence go like you you
will converge with an appropriate step
size and and so and again it follows by
some sort of gradient descent style
argument happy to talk about it
all right let's thank guy and Michael
again
[Applause]